philippine heritage month we're
celebrating here in canada
and i gotta say like you have become
like
such a huge figure in the community um
not only inspiring young people but like
i was talking to an aunt of mine just
the other day and i was like oh i'm
gonna interview jokoy i'm mentioning
joko it's amazing and she goes oh joko
and she went into the [ __ ] you did the
whole bit yeah how you got your name and
all that so you know like what does it
feel like to you to know that you've
reached across
just like every generation especially at
filipinos i know i and
you know what i love the most is
uh like yesterday someone just posted on
instagram i was at a at a bar
with uh with my lady
and uh the waiter came up to me and he's
like my mom and i love you it's a white
guy
and and he goes
my mom and i just go josep joseph
and it's like that's the kind of stuff
that i always wanted you know i when i
was trying to do
uh when i was doing stand-up when i
first started you know i wanted to talk
about filipino but i didn't want to do
the whole
sticky
the difference between filipinos and
black people and the difference between
filipinos and white people i didn't want
to do that i just wanted to be able to
tell you i was filipino without telling
you i was filipino and and it all
started with just
being my mom on stage just telling the
stories between my mom and i
and
and that's it and and when that started
happening i started noticing everyone
just latching on to this character and
and and identifying and relating to it
you know like
yeah she's filipino but she's just a mom
she's just like your mom there's no
difference between my mom and your mom
uh it's just my mom speaks two languages
fluently that's it
you know so
yeah and i love that i love that people
can relate and identify and
and it just feels good that
i was gonna do it anyway man like you
know what i mean like
but to be able to say like wow people
are
really supporting this and proud of it
and and it makes people
you know pr you know proud and they have
a voice you know in this community of
entertainment that we're in that's just
so
racially biased you know what i mean
that
finally there's there's another voice
out there that's being heard and and i
hope that this door opens i don't say
hope i it will open other doors and
you'll hear other voices you know what i
mean and and
you pay homage to the ones that that
were there before us you know like
margaret show and and you know all the
other cats that came up before us but
but man it feels good to be able to to
hold this flag up high right now yeah
dude what what is it about comedy
specifically that is the perfect vehicle
for that you mentioned margaret show and
you know when i was growing up a lot of
my favorite comedians were just like all
diverse all different backgrounds all
different stories what is it about
comedy specifically that lends itself to
being able to do that for people because
it's your your chance to feel
you know no no longer uh
how do i say it you you don't feel
oh how do i want to say it man i want to
say it the right way
um
it gives you a chance to
have an identity right so when you latch
onto comedy
you get to hear the funny side of
something that you feel embarrassed
about sometimes especially when you grow
up
during the times that i did the 70s and
80s and my mom came to the states in the
late 60s you know the height you know
the racism was huge you know what i mean
and to be able to come to this country
and and not really have an identity or a
voice and you turn on the channels and
you don't see you anywhere represented
and
you know you latch on to comedy because
you hear a funny take on something that
can be relatable and i think that's why
when
when i was coming up i identify with
black people so much black comedy
because
the rawness and and them telling their
story about how their mom and their dad
and their uncle was you know like when i
hear stories from eddie murphy or
richard pryor
you know
i i just identified with it because
there were
there there was nothing that i could
identify with
i don't know how to say it but it's just
something about
hearing that story and about that family
situation
in a country where i wasn't being you
know being identified or recognized i
latched on to black comedy and that's
what comedy does it makes you gravitate
and and feel accepted and relatable
you know when i was growing up i
couldn't even be made fun of for being
filipino because my friends didn't know
what that was yeah
in other schools they didn't know what
it was they didn't know how old are you
i'm 40. 40. you know what i mean that
wasn't that long ago right and so i
again like you i lashed onto
all sorts of different things but now
we're seeing this wave and so i related
to this my brother's a chef and years
ago he said filipino food is the next
wave it's the next wave after thai food
is the next thing and it became an
entirely cultural thing that just
started
when did you really feel it start to
come in and people really started to
take notice about who we were what our
stories were you know
i finally found it
um i started feeling it in the clubs
you know about 15 years ago
you know when i did jay leno i did jay
leno and i got a standing o and you know
when you watch my my routine you're
going to be like oh wow you know he's
doing that
racial stereotype style of
humor but you got to understand the time
that i came in you know what i'm saying
you got to understand like
when i came into the scene
you you had to like change your act
because you always were dealt with
you know producers or or executives
going we don't get it we don't get it
and and then you have to keep doing
these things until they go okay we get
that so do more of that you know and as
long as you laugh then i was happy so
it's like it sucks but that's how it was
during our generation it wasn't until
later on that i was just like now i
gotta tell you my story and i gotta tell
you who i really am you know what i mean
and stop making fun of us but
hear us and laugh with us and and i
started feeling that
right around my my first uh
our special
on comedy central and i and i you know i
did this joke about my mom playing the
wii with my son and
and i mean everyone just started coming
up to me no matter what color latino
black
other asians you know white people they
were just coming up to me with weak
controllers and weak controllers they
had me sign them and they were like
my mom plays the weed just like your mom
and and that's when i realized like
oh it's happening you know what i mean
people are like
seeing us and people are
feeling us right now you know what i
mean so i i feel like right around that
special is when it started that's when i
started feeling this movement you know
yeah i'm not like not to get you up too
much just because we're on the interview
but i remember the first time i saw you
and stand up and it was like a
revelation because i was like
oh like this dude's telling the jokes
that we tell
yeah
like it was amazing it was so cool thank
you
i know the filipinos are funny right
yeah we're funny people like we love to
laugh and and it was that that was the
most important part was i wanted people
to see just how
indirectly funny my mom was you know she
she was just and i noticed that
you know
with other filipino friends of mine they
were like my mom does that too and it's
just like the more i did that then i
started seeing other people do and i was
just like
yeah i got to get more of these stories
out man and then i was addicted i was
like i can't wait till
if you like that story you're gonna love
this story so it just kept going and
kept snowballing and i love it so you're
going back to manila this summer right
yeah dude
what how how are you anticipating that
to be because last like the special that
you did
from there before was wild what do you
think the response is going gonna be
like it's gonna be nuts now i mean you
know when i shot that special in his
elements by the way i did that and i
told netflix
uh this can't be a netflix philippine
special this has to be a netflix
worldwide special and i wanna i want
people to see
my culture and i go just give me five
minutes to show what my food looks like
give me five minutes to show show them
what my country looks like let me give
me five minutes to show what filipinos
look like talk like laugh like and uh
and we'll have ourselves a really cool
show you know what i mean just give me
that one moment
and uh and they did that for me
and uh we shot that on a monday and
tuesday and then on a wednesday
i i did the moa arena it was like 14 000
people after we did that taping and it
was just
the love was incredible man and and now
with
you know this movie coming out we're
doing a premiere out there now
you know we're going to premiere for
easter sunday and then we're going to do
a show at the same arena so
it's going to be it's going to be crazy
it's going to be nuts man
easter sunday is something that we're
all paying attention to and i'm really
excited for one one thing i noticed is
that when you guys were filming out in
bc there was a casting call that went
out like just filipinos hey if it
doesn't matter what you look like how
big small how old whatever just come out
and and like participate and we'll see
if we have a part for you how important
was that to you to kind of get the
community involved because it's supposed
to be a big family affair yeah well that
was the one thing i asked
amblin when they gave me the deal you
know i told holly and jeb and you know
and of course stephen was on board and
and uh the one thing i said is we're not
gonna make fun of filipinos we're gonna
we're gonna shine the light on filipinos
and and and
we're just gonna be a family and i
wanted every character to be represented
and i didn't want the over-the-top
accents i just want my mom to be my mom
and that was so important to me with
lydia lydia gaston she crushed my mom
and you know when we did the the test
the test between her and the chemistry
test the one thing i said when i pulled
her to the side is go
you know it's very important that we
nail my mom you know what i mean because
my fans are gonna be like
that doesn't sound like her you know and
i wanted to like really show the world
like
you know this beautiful filipino woman
you know what i mean this strong
filipino woman that's just
doing her best to raise this family you
know and and
lydia knocked it out of the park so
i wanted this cast call to just be
filipino specific you know what i mean
like this is that moment where i get to
say hey
90 of this cast on this big budget movie
is filipino so come one come all and
show us what you got and
and i i feel like we got the best we got
the best of the best we got some
canadians in there too that made me
happy yeah man it's i'm so excited now i
noticed that you logged on you're on
chelsea's computer
chelsea handler
yeah
yeah are you guys like sharing passwords
now is that no
so here's the thing she's on a huge
major tour i'm on a huge major tour and
it's just
it's
when i meet up with her
i don't have my laptops
so whenever i do like a facetime call or
a zoom i have to use chelsea's and
here's the thing i completely forgot
that this is chelsea so it's and i keep
forgetting that it says chelsea handler
on the other end of this
on the screen so yeah it's hers and we
just whenever she's on tour uh on my day
off i'm gonna fly over to her city and
hang out with her for a few days and
then she does the same thing with me
that's awesome you guys know each other
for a long time
do you run stuff by each other like do
you test material out on each other yeah
you know she's really she's just so
naturally funny man like she's she's got
some serious chops and uh and she's
getting ready to shoot her hour right
now and
you know i give her my little
hints and whatever i can give her you
know punch-ups you know and she takes
some and then and then and then some
she's like no that's not gonna work and
that's fine and i love that about her
you know what i mean so
she writes all her stuff and
and i and and she she helps me too when
i get off stage she always gives me
little uh punch-ups for me and
it's kind of cool man it's such a cool
relationship we've known each other for
oh my god 17 years now so yeah yeah she
had a show called chelsea lately i it
was in canada right yeah so you watch
that show yeah and i was you know i was
on that show a lot and i was supposed to
be the sidekick i was supposed to be
chewy and uh you know originally and i
turned it down because i wanted to do
stand-up i was like i really don't want
to be known as a sidekick i want to be
my own thing so
yeah that was the beginning of a
relationship me turning her down and she
was not happy about it so
but look where we're at now
well listen we're like there's a lot of
talk going around about what's gonna
happen when after gordon leaves his show
what's up what are the chances that you
two might be taking that out that would
be funny huh no it's uh creatively i i i
i want more movies you know what i mean
i want to i want to get more of that
message out there and and get
you know for me like that's opening the
door for
other uh people like me and i don't just
mean filipino i'm talking like the
others you know what i mean
other asians and and i want to try
not try but i will create more
opportunities like this that's all i
want to do man is just keep opening
these doors and see the the young cats
come up there's a lot of them just in
the filipinos alone i'm getting so proud
man i'm so happy man i saw a cat you
know andrew lopez joey gila and uh j.r
de guzman like these guys are
funny man and they're coming up and and
you know that's what i want to see more
of
you've talked so much about getting this
kind of drive from your mom do you does
your son have the same kind of drive
that you guys have
uh yeah well
my son is so funny
it's just so naturally funny and it's
it's uh it's
it's damn near scary
you know like he's he's got uh he's got
better chops than me when i was his age
but uh yeah it's kind of like damn man
like he's hitting some of these out of
the park just us riffing when we're
talking i'm like oh he got that one on
me all right i got that so uh i'd love
to see him hit the stage i always hint
you know because he likes to go to
comedy clubs with me on my off days and
and uh
and he'll he'll hint like he's about to
go up but then he doesn't but i i feel
like it's coming man i feel like he's
gonna get up on stage one day
does he appreciate a good dad joke you
must have a ton of fun i i have a lot
and he's he's quick to tell me that
that's a dad joke and it's lame he
always says it to me but i think it just
comes with the age
you know
there's just an age you hit and then all
of a sudden you're a dad joke guy and i
kick myself every time i say stupid
stuff like
like oh look at that building it's
beautiful like what am i saying i've
never said look at that building
to my son like my son's supposed to go
oh yeah that is a cool building like
yeah it's it's
it's pretty funny my son has caught me
several times doing dad stuff and it's
uh it's it's pretty lame but hey that's
what happens when you're 50 bro you're
walking around with your hands behind
your back appreciating nature yeah yeah
yeah dude
yeah
hilarious what's a good bad joke what's
your what's your best one oh man i i got
i don't know it comes during the day
it's like it's like
you know he'll say something and then i
i i'll repeat it in a funny way and it's
just like what am i doing and even he's
like oh that's horrible dad i don't have
any written down
let's just say i when i'm around him all
of a sudden i'm a dad
perfect
dude that's awesome hey listen i i
appreciate you so much thank you so much
for the time uh it's been such a such an
honor and pleasure to chat with you man
oh man thank you dude